it's usually a pretty good shooter too
another play maker as well can handle it
picking rolls
[Music]
[Applause]
home
something that's been a season-long
issue the Vincenzo better pass to full
better pass to play open three yes sir
[Music]
well they're 27th in the league in
three-point shooting percentage Anthony
Lam has subbed in
and he lasered it in anyway he's got 11.
you can let Atlanta bomb away as long as
they want one of nine on threes right
now yeah you're clogging up the paint
make them beat you over time
we said on the home
[Applause]
stands fine all kinds of openings John
Collins the fundamentals come on youth
basketball is hysterical right now
everybody thinks they're Steph Curry
it's a different basketball world
[Applause]
[Music]
I love what Klay Thompson just did there
or you should get it fairly easy two for
one here
[Applause]
[Music]
gotta watch Klay Thompson's movements he
wait the way he sets up people and the
way he cut unfortunately for John it's
been a problem all year I mean he's
missing wife right
setting up play
elbow jumper perfect
his two teammates and then here's the
jumper he's just feeling good now when
when dejante Murray wins
it away lamb will handle the break lamb
down the lane land of the trailing play
Thompson to lay it in it's an important
stress because you could tell the Hawks
are just trying to make it doable eight
eight and three for kavan and 17 really
good minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
I love the way the Warriors are moving
without the ball
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oon
[Applause]
got a piece of his man there a case but
this is the game right now Klay Thompson
keeping the ward kept a float by Clay
threes but the Hawks are making their
push now and playing just keeps pushing
back a lot of dribbling and a lot less
passing
Glam the open three-point shooter clay
sneaking into Lane and he's like y'all
don't want to give me the ball I'm gonna
go get it four rings Lake Thompson it's
my night I got 36.
young finally misses
even chenzo running with pool
playing the trail three he got it
find that man Atlanta just breathes the
Cyber Leaf if anyone not named Klay
Thompson is shooting
[Applause]
[Music]
Dante Murray clay pulled the nicodawa
you should get two possessions to their
one can you score twice and come up with
a stop in between if you need it Klay
Thompson three
feels like a must score for the Warriors
this trip down
and he's got 46. what are you running
here nothing split
[Music]
playing
get the ball to play and get out of the
way he's tied the game again tonight for
Klay Thompson nothing going on Draymond
a beautiful screen
plays 9th three of the night former
Warrior
[Music]
play three
[Music]
is 50 points he's got 52 in the lead in
Atlanta takes time in 41 minutes 10 made
threes and the lead again just a
flamethrower they didn't even need to
make a great move
[Music]
rule to beat the buzzer off back
up and Looney kept it to play good luck
for the Baseline and we're tied again
play turn in the corner to a cunning
lamb step through laying in
I love that lamb just moved